what is the average rate of change of Y
of X over the interval negative 5 is
less than X is less than negative 2 so
this is X is equal to negative 5 when X
is equal to negative 5 y of X is equal
to 6 and when X is equal to negative 2 y
of X is equal to 0 so to figure out the
average rate of change so the average
rate of change of Y of X with respect
and we can assume it's with respect to X
with respect to X let me make that a
little bit neater with respect to X this
is going to be the change in Y of X over
that interval over the change of X of
that interval and the shorthand for
change is this triangle symbol Delta
Delta Y I'll just write Y I could write
Delta Y of X its Delta Y change in Y
over our change in X that's going to be
our average rate of change over this
interval so how much did Y change over
this interval so Y went from a 6 to 0 so
let's say that this is we can kind of
view this as our end point right over
here so this is our end this is our
start and we could have done it the
other way around we would get a
consistent result but since this is
higher up on the list let's call this
the start and this is the X as a lower
value we'll call that our start this is
our end so we start at 6 we end at 0 so
our change in Y is going to be negative
6 we went down by 6 in the Y direction
it's negative 6 you could say that's 0
minus 6 and our change in X well we were
at negative 5 and we go up to negative 2
we increased by 3 so we increased by 3
so we went when we increase X by 3 we
went we decreased Y of X by 6 or if we
want to simplify this right over here
negative 6 over 3 is the same thing as
negative 2 so our average rate of change
of Y of X over the interval from
negative 5 to negative 2 is negative 2
every time on
bridge-ex increased 1y went down by
negative 2